I have to say [ __ ] you very much I
appreciate that let me just start up by
say something I cannot believe that it's
already October let me tell you folks
when you get to my age life goes too
fast October I turn on the TV the other
day I thought oh they advertising
jack-o'-lanterns already it was just
Trump
every time I think he's gonna go down in
the polls he goes up at the polls this
guy I think really thinks he's gonna be
President and I could be and you know
how I know this because now the wife has
started to do interviews did you see
that is his Slovenian wife Melania did
her first interview because she might be
the first lady and you know when you're
the first lady you always acted a little
first lady project right like Laura Bush
had literacy and Michelle Obama has
childhood obesity and now
Melania said she wants to make sure that
young girls know how to work the pole I
mean I meant walk the runway I misspoke
but then they asked Melania what she
thought about her her husband you know
wanting to deport all the Mexicans and
she said look I'm from the Balkans I
know ethnic cleansing I think he can do
it but speaking of that someone has
started a pointless military operation
in the Middle East and for once it
wasn't us that's right
Russia is bombing sub Vladimir Putin
would like to take Syria off of our
hands and I have one word for him
sold sold let's let's get him to sign
the papers before we Sobers up I mean
that's like selling a diesel Volkswagen
with blood on the tires I am for it
but of course we'll never do that
because it would make too much sense
instead America and Russia are fighting
over Syria like it's a girl meanwhile
neither one of us wants have anything to
do with Afghanistan we're like that
[ __ ] is crazy but this is serious I
mean if Russia shoots down one of our
planes or vice versa you know this could
be World War 3 you could go nuclear and
then we will never get to the bottom of
what's in Hillary's emails oh yeah yeah
let's just say this week Russian hackers
have tried to hack into Hillary's emails
five times now you know what she is the
most boring person in the world and
everyone wants to read her emails I
don't understand this and here's the
weird thing about you know running as
she does the Clinton Foundation Global
Initiative and also getting spam when a
Nigerian prince emails you and says gee
it says he's never met you and wants to
move millions into your bank account he
actually means it now
now I'm sure you so we had another
horrific school shooting this week and
of course as it always happens every
Republican in Congress said this is
awful but we cannot politicize tragedy
now for excuse us we'll have to get back
to our Benghazi hearings the irony of
getting back to the Benghazi hearing all
right now how we stated over there in
case we the folks had missed that one
but and then Kevin McCarthy you're
familiar with this guy he's the one
who's going to replace he's from
California he's going to replace John
Boehner as the Speaker of the House and
he was kind of pulled to Boehner he was
on it was on on Hannity and Hannity was
asking about you know what are your
accomplishments and he said the words he
said well everybody thought Hillary was
unbeatable and then we put together a
Benghazi committee and what are her
numbers now dropping and his fellow
Republicans are a little upset but he
let their true motives out of the bag
and Fox News was furious that he broke
with their format and said something
true
but here's some good news for liberals
they got the Pope back today you know
they thought they lost the Pope this
week because it would came out that he
had a private meeting with Kim Davis and
Francis must have gotten an earful from
the gay community and when I say the gay
community I mean the guys back at the
Vatican but all is well today the
Vatican totally walked it back they said
first of all it was a very very brief
meeting it was a wham bam bless you
ma'am and he doesn't endorse the Pope
doesn't endorse what Kim Davis stands
for and most important they said for a
holy man like the Pope it's important
that he spend time with a woman like Kim
Davis to remind him that a lifetime of
abstinence isn't so bad
okay now three more women have come
forward to accuse Bill Cosby of
assaulting them bringing the grand total
to North America I don't know what just
I don't know what to say anymore about
this guy except he has tranquilized more
women than scented candles
you